FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome,
everyone.
Thank you for coming to this
Pride Month event as we wait
for what we hope will be
good news from the US
Supreme Court soon.
I wanted to thank Jimmy
and Pam for
inviting me to do this.
I am very excited to meet these
three great supporters
of gay marriage and excellent
football players, as well.
We have Chris Kluwe, Brendon
Ayanbadejo, and Scott Fujita.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: I will just tell
you a little bit about
each of these guys.
You probably know most of it,
and then we'll go right into
some questions that I have
for them and then
Q&A from the audience.
So Chris joined the Oakland
Raiders recently, after many
years as the--
CHRIS KLUWE: That picture.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: --as the
Minnesota Vikings punter.
Chris played for UCLA and went
to high school in California.
He is an avid Guitar Hero and
World of Warcraft player, as
well as a bassist in a band
he founded in Minneapolis.
His first book, a collection of
essays, is due out at the
end of June and is titled
"Beautifully Unique Sparkle
Pony."
We'll ask him little
bit about that.
You probably know where
that comes from.
Chris is well known for the
letter he wrote in September
of last year to Maryland
State Assembly
Delegate Emmett Burns--
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: --who had sent
a letter to the owners of the
Baltimore Ravens, requesting
that they keep Brendon from
speaking out publicly
in favor of
legalization of gay marriage.
Chris, along with Brendon and
Scott and a number of other
professional athletes, filed an
amicus brief in the Prop 8
case before the Supreme Court.
And in March of 2013, Chris
joined Athlete Ally, an
organization focused on stopping
homophobia and
transphobia in sports,
as an ambassador.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about that
organization, as well.
Brendon is a linebacker, who
most recently played for the
Super Bowl Champion
Baltimore Ravens--
sorry to the Niners' fans.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: He was.
He was a linebacker, he was.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Brendon also
played for UCLA and went to
high school in California.
Brendon has been a strong
advocate for gay marriage
since 2009.
And as I mentioned, he wound up
in this firestorm when this
Maryland State Assembly Delegate
asked the team's
leadership to keep him from
expressing his opinions.
And he responded that he had
no intention of remaining
silent on an issue of conscience
and public
importance.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Brendon serves
as Chairman of the Athlete
Ally advisory board.
He's, also, working on an
MBA at George Washington
University, and I understand,
hopes to become a university
athletic director at
UCLA, ideally.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Down the
line, when I'm a little bit
more mature, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: --and
is writing a
column for Fox Sports.
Scott, very recently, retired
after many years as a
linebacker, including with
the Saints when they
won the Super Bowl.
Scott graduated from
Berkeley--
go Bears--
and was born in California.
Scott first vocalized his
support for marriage equality
in 2009, and then again in
March, 2013, he wrote an
article in the "New York Times,"
expressing his support
for LGBT equality, dispelling
the notion that football
players, football as a sport,
and LGBT acceptance don't mix.
Scott emphasized that he would
embrace a teammate, were the
teammate to come out
of the closet.
Scott is, also, actively
involved in many other causes,
some of which we'll talk about,
such as promoting
adoption, breast cancer
awareness, the Gulf
restoration network,
and Team Gleason.
And so with that, I
will start asking
you guys some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: And thank
you, again, for coming.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Can
I say one thing
about Berkeley, though.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You can.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: I love
Berkeley, and they're our
sister school, and they invented
the quarter system.
And then they dropped it and
went to semesters, but UCLA
had to keep it, so.
SCOTT FUJITA: And UCLA
is Berkeley's
little sister school.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO:
Right, well--
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT FUJITA: We steal
Berkeley's fight songs.
CHRIS KLUWE: But we play
it much better.
SCOTT FUJITA: And I don't know
if we ever beat them or not.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: But we
beat them in football.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO:
Basketball.
But we digress.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All right.
I went to Michigan, so I think
the Big 10 is better.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KLUWE: Boo.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So starting
with Chris, why don't we,
just, have each of you talk a
little bit about how you got
involved in advocating for
marriage equality.
CHRIS KLUWE: So essentially, I
got involved in the off season
last year when a group called
Minnesotans For Marriage
Equality contacted me on Twitter
and said, hey, would
you like to help us defeat this
constitutional amendment
in Minnesota that was going
to ban same sex marriage.
And I said, yeah, that seems
like a great thing to do.
I don't think anyone should
be banned from
marrying each other.
And so got I involved with them,
recorded a couple of
radio ads and then did
a fundraising dinner.
And then I saw the letter that
Delegate Burns had written to
the Ravens about Brendon.
And it made me really upset,
because it was a First
Amendment violation from elected
US Representative.
And it was also the fact
that, why do you care?
What does it matter to you if
two people who love each other
want to get married.
That doesn't affect your
life in the slightest.
And so I wrote a letter back,
which, then, Deadspin
published, and a lot
of people saw.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KLUWE: And then it kind of
broadened the platform that
I was able to speak on,
and so I said, OK.
Well I have this platform.
Now I have a chance to use it,
and hopefully, make people's
lives better.
And from that point on, I was,
like, OK, here we go.
Let's make people aware that
you have to have empathy.
You have to treat people the
way you would want to be
treated in order to have a
functional society, so that's
how I got involved.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Brendon?
BRENDON AYANBADEJO:
Well for me, it's
a little bit different.
I think, just innately, these
two gentlemen, they understand
freedom and what this
Constitution guarantees to our
fellow citizens, but for me,
it was more of a life
experience type of thing.
So my dad's Nigerian,
and my mom is Irish.
So my dad's as dark
as coffee, and my
mom's as white as cream.
And I came out this beautiful
caramel macchiato color.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS KLUWE: Humble, too.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Yeah,
it's beautiful, I know--
a lot of mosquito bites.
So there was a time prior
to my parents' meeting--
the monumental case, Loving
versus Virginia in the late
'60s, and that prevented
interracial couples, so
anti-miscegenation laws.
So I had always thought, you
know, man, if my parents had
met in the '60s, I don't know
if I'd, even, be here today.
And as we progress into the
future, you know, my wife,
here--she's sitting in the front
row-- she's also a mixed
breed, like myself.
Second row, sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: And then
my beautiful children, as
well, that are here, tearing
shit up, like usual.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: They're,
also, beautiful mixed kids,
and eventually, everyone's
going to be mixed.
But could you imagine living
in a society where-- oh no,
there's no racial mixing.
So let's fast forward
to today--
actually, let's go to 2009.
I felt compelled to
write a letter--
and open-faced letter
to President Obama--
and I titled it "Same Sex
Marriage, What's the Big
Deal." And that got published in
the "Huffington Post," and
not as many people read
it as Chris' article.
CHRIS KLUWE: You've
got to swear more.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: It wasn't as
well written, but I was the
first professional athlete
to publicly
support marriage equality.
But really what compelled
me to write
it was Britney Spears.
And she had gone to Vegas, and
she met a young bloke, and
they hit it off for a couple
of nights, hitched it.
And they had, instantly, more
rights than some of my friends
that had been together
for 25 years.
So I wrote the article,
published it, and all of the
sudden in 2009, I became gay.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Everyone
said I was gay.
And I guess in 2011, I was
bisexual, and in 2013, I think
they're accepting my
heterosexuality
after a couple of kids.
[CELL PHONE RINGS]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO:
So-- oh snap,
that's a fine, I'm sorry.
This is definitely a fine.
[COUGHING]
CHRIS KLUWE: That's what
we do in meeting rooms.
You've got to cover
for people who--
their phones go off.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: And so for
me, it's kind of a life
experience thing and just
knowing what it feels like to
be on the other side and knowing
what our LGBT brothers
and sisters are going
through, even though
I'm a straight ally.
So I don't to the fullest
extent, but I totally equate
this to equal rights
and human rights.
Everyone says why are you so a
champion for gay rights or
LGBT rights.
No, I'm just a champion for
rights, for equal rights, so
that was the genesis.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT FUJITA: What
they both said.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT FUJITA: No, I
mean, I think, why
do I support equality?
I think, would common sense not
be a satisfactory answer?
You know, why is common
sense not enough?
For me, I share a lot
of the same stories.
My father is Japanese-American,
was
interned during World War II in
an Arizona relocation camp
in the desert.
My mother's Caucasian, so like
these guys, I also have an
experience with interracial
marriage,
like Brendon's folks.
Chris is married to someone
of a different race.
So we were all impacted by
Loving versus Virginia.
And I think at its root, for my
family, this is something
that impacted us.
I'm also adopted.
That's why I don't
look Japanese.
I got the name, not the blood.
I feel Japanese at
heart, though.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT FUJITA: When I was living
in Louisiana, I read
about a measure that was being
proposed in Arkansas, and it
was something like "The Single
Parent Adoption Ban." And the
whole idea was to prevent
single parents
from adopting children.
And this is in a place in the
South where there are
thousands of foster children
who just become
institutionalized.
And this law, to me, was code
for "Gay People Can't Adopt."
And as an adopted child,
I just took a lot
of offense to that.
And the message that was sending
was it's better to
have kids, again,
institutionalized in foster
care without a safe, loving,
permanent home, rather than
having, you know, one, two
parents, whatever it is, who
are willing to provide that
permanent home for them.
It just made no sense to me.
So coupling those two things
together-- again, being
adopted, mixed race parents,
having some friends in the
LGBT community who have been
impacted by this, as well--
it, just, became important for
me to talk about this.
I think the first time I
mentioned the idea of marriage
equality was in a locker room
in an interview in 2007.
The interviewer looked at me
like I was crazy, like what
the hell is he talking about,
what's marriage equality.
And someone said, oh,
that's gay marriage.
And I said, I don't, even, like
the idea of calling it
gay marriage, to tell
you the truth.
I mean, I don't call
my marriage to my
wife straight marriage.
It's just marriage,
and words matter.
Language matters.
And when I was at the GLAAD
awards down in Los Angeles in
2009, at the table I was at,
there was a young lady there.
And she pulls me aside, at one
point with my wife, and shares
a story with me about her
younger brother who had come
out, at one point, as gay to
his unsuspecting, very
unsupportive father.
And the father really,
just, wrote him off.
And her brother ended up
taking his own life.
And she said that her father was
sort of a man's man-- you
know, whatever that means, a big
football guy-- you know,
really looked up to
me as a player.
And when he heard me talking
about the issue of marriage
equality and gays, in general,
it started to force him to
reconsider his feelings
about it.
So she challenged me.
She said, it takes people like
you for people like my dad to
be able to open their
mind a little bit.
So she said, please keep
talking about this.
And I'm just honored to stand
up, be up here with these guys
in a growing community and to
have watched the conversation
evolve the way it has.
Just since 2007, when I first
uttered "marriage equality,"
no one knew what that meant.
And now it's, finally,
on people's radar.
People are talking about it.
The conversation has evolved.
And it's to the point now,
where, hopefully, we have a
landmark hearing, here, in a
little bit, and the decision
comes through that grants
equality for everybody.
That's what we're
all here for.
That's what we're all
fighting for.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: I have another
question for all of you.
Why don't we start with
Brendon, this time.
What's been your experience with
homophobia in the NFL?
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: It's been
evolving, and that's a
beautiful thing.
So early on--
I'd say silence is consent--
and so when you hear these
words, these slurs being
thrown around, I would, always,
say, hey, you know you
can't say that.
You don't need to
say "no homo."
You don't need to say
the f word, or
replace dumb with gay.
So after years and years of
ingraining this into guys'
heads, I went from 20 times a
day, and then after a couple
of years, you know, it
was 19.5 times a day.
So I was keeping metrics.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We like
that in people.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO:
Yeah, it wasn't
working, but it was working.
It's come full circle to, you
know, not really knowing of
any allies, not really knowing
that, publicly, that he
supported LGBT rights to, you
know, Kluwe stepping up, to
other players stepping up.
And now we have this
t-shirt, now.
And so this t-shirt, here, the
NFLPA endorsed this shirt.
So DeMaurice Smith, our
Executive Director, he
supports LGBT rights,
and so does our
President, Domonique Foxworth.
So I approached them with an
idea, one day, that we need to
come up with some type of
endorsement for LGBT rights.
And it was something as simple
as a t-shirt, and the proceeds
will go towards LGBT
advocacy groups.
And that's how far we've come--
from people calling me
the three-letter f word to,
now, everybody starting to
build this critical mass.
And they're starting to see
that everybody deserves
equality, but I think the most
important thing is we are
having the conversation.
And even if guys don't support
it, we're having the
conversation.
And guys are learning things
and they're hearing things
that they never heard before--
from people being born gay--
they've never heard that
before-- to being
gay is not a sin.
And you know, you've been taught
this, basically, since
the day you came out via
religion and other things in
ignorance, that being gay is
perfectly normal, and God
created you that way.
We're having the conversation,
and that's where we've come.
SCOTT FUJITA: Yeah, I'm so glad
Brendon mentioned the
idea for these t-shirts.
I mean, it's a great
idea by him.
I sit on the executive committee
as a Vice President
for our players' union.
I've been on the board,
now, for four years.
You know, as me, I'm always
viewed as the, sort of,
gay-loving, tree-hugging
socialist from Berkeley.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT FUJITA: I like the idea
of the union getting behind
more social progressive issues,
but I was, also,
elected to be in this position
where you have to take
everybody's feelings
into consideration.
And advancing ideas like that--
you know, good for the
broader membership--
so to have someone like Brendon,
who is a new player
rep, come in with this great
idea and have our leadership
embrace it like that,
it's huge.
It's huge.
And again, it's not so much
about a political issue.
And that's one of the things
that we, always, struggle
with, trying to convey to, not
just our members in the
players' union, but,
really, everybody.
It's not a political issue.
This is a people issue.
It's a people issue
about people.
And that's the struggle.
It's changing the conversation
so that people
understand it that way.
And I'm glad we're getting to
the point where we can have
the conversation.
CHRIS KLUWE: Yeah, and it's,
also, from what I've seen, the
younger players coming into the
NFL are raised more in an
environment of tolerance and
respect, and that's just the
world that they're
growing up in.
And you can, really, see that
in their attitudes, because
they look at this issue, and
they're like, well, who cares?
Why does anyone care
who you marry?
And you know, it's not all of
them, because just like
society, it's not everyone.
But the tide is shifting, and
you're starting to see that
more and more in the views of
the younger generation.
And that's something that we
just have to keep working at
it and realize that this is
a generational issue.
It's like suffrage.
It's like segregation.
It's like slavery.
It's something that time
is going to change.
And we have to keep working at
it to keep changing it, but
it's also going to
take a while.
There are no easy fixes.
And I've said it before, you,
basically, have to wait for
the old people to
die off, and--
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KLUWE: You let the young
people take their place.
That's really what fixes it.
So it's good to see that
happening in the NFL, that you
see those young people keep
cycling through--
not the dying off part.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Can I
make a point real quick?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Please do.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: One thing
that we do see-- and I can't
blame the guys themselves,
because the biggest role model
that we do have is
the government.
And if the government continues
to discriminate, and
if you can still be fired in
38 states for being a part
LGBT community, if you can still
be evicted from your
home for being a part of LGBT
community, then you shouldn't
be so shocked when you find
people in our society that are
bigots and that are saying some
of the things that they
say and that discriminate.
So it's from the top down
from the bottom up.
The people have to change,
and the government has
to change with it.
CHRIS KLUWE: And those are the
things that we can work on.
That's what we can change.
I mean, that's the part where we
set the structure in place
that people know that, hey,
this is where society is
heading, and my behavior--
where I'm not tolerating
other people--
that's not accepted anymore.
That's not proper behavior
SCOTT FUJITA: Yeah, I think
Brendon says it best.
It's about rights.
If people can't wrap their heads
around the idea of gay
rights or calling it
gay rights, just
call it rights, then.
It's that simple.
And I think in this country,
it does come down to the
government.
We discriminate against people
for all kinds of reasons.
But with an issue like this,
you need an evidence-based
rationale to be able
to discriminate.
I haven't heard one yet.
And we're still discriminating
against
members of the LGBT community.
It's so hard to say.
It's a mouthful.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Can we come
up with a new acronym?
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT FUJITA: You know, we
discriminate against people
who are 16 years old.
You have to be 16 to get your
driver's license, because
evidence suggests that people
under 16 are going to be
irresponsible and get
into an accident.
We discriminate against people
under 21 and say they can't
drink, because evidence
suggests they'll be
irresponsible and get into
some kind of trouble.
We discriminate against--
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: They
can go to war, though.
SCOTT FUJITA: Yeah, right.
They can go to war.
We discriminate others who get
to a certain age and say they
can no longer drive, because
evidence suggests that they'll
be a hazard on the road.
So again, there is no evidence
to suggest that this will be
dangerous or harmful
to society.
It's just about rights, as
Brendon always says.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Chris, I have a
follow-up question for you,
if you're comfortable
answering it.
CHRIS KLUWE: Sure.
FEMALE SPEAKER: One of your
former teammates, Adrian
Peterson, recently came out--
"came out" is probably the
wrong way of putting it--
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: --on
the radio--
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Yeah,
that's wrong.
FEMALE SPEAKER: He made a
statement, something to the
effect of, "I'm not with gay
marriage." And then he
clarified it, later, by saying
he was OK if other people were
in favor, but he wasn't.
Have you talked to him
about that at all?
CHRIS KLUWE: I haven't
talked to Adrian,
recently, about that.
We were good friends
in the locker room.
And for me, the fact that Adrian
is willing to let other
people have their rights-- while
that's not the ideal
situation, it's, really, the
best we can hope for from a
lot of people is the fact that
as long as you're not
discriminating against people,
you don't have to actually
embrace it.
You know, we would like to get
the point where everyone is
embracing the idea that you
treat other people the way
you'd like to be treated.
But while we're working towards
that, avoiding active
discrimination is one of the
steps to that process.
And so with Adrian, he may not,
personally, agree with
same sex marriage.
He may not, personally, agree
for gay rights, but he's not,
actively, going out his way
to rally against it.
And that's something
that I would
like to see him embrace--
gay rights-- because it's
human rights, something
everyone should have,
But at the end of the day, I'm
not going to crucify him for
being who he is, being raised
in the environment that
he was raised in.
And you know, even saying what
he said, that can be tough to
do if you raised in a very
religious environment.
So I'm not upset at Adrian.
I would wish he would he could
do more, but at the same time,
he's not actively trying to
conspire against LGBT rights.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right.
CHRIS KLUWE: If that makes
sense to anyone.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Brendon, can you
tell us a little bit about
Athlete Ally?
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Yes, so
Athlete Ally is a group that
tries to foster inclusion
of the LGBT
community into sports.
So we go around, and we speak
at different schools.
And we just talk about
LGBT sensitivity.
The last thing we want is--
you know, imagine Greg Louganis,
if he didn't
continue to be the greatest
American diver in history--
and he's one of my role models
and one of my heroes.
But imagine if he got bullied
out of diving, because there
were some straight kids, and
they made fun of him, because
he was a part of the
LGBT community.
So we want to foster kids.
And we want to encourage them
to continue to play sports,
especially with all the problems
we have with heart
disease and diabetes and people
being so sedentary.
The last thing we want to see is
our children being bullied
out of sports.
And so I think once you see
somebody like Jason Collins--
on that level, 7 foot tall
black dude that's gay--
it destroys a lot of people's
perception of what
they think gay is.
And now, oh my god, there's
an athlete in the
NBA, and he's gay.
And there's Chris Kluwe and
Scott Fujita, and they're
straight guys, and they believe
in me, and they
support me.
So we think we can do so much
in helping young people,
curbing suicide rates, letting
kids stand a little bit taller
that are part of the
LGBT community--
gosh darn, it is hard.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: And we'll
curb suicide rates.
And kids, ultimately, they'll
get better educations.
They'll feel better about
themselves, and they'll go on
to be successful Americans, just
by the littlest thing, a
little bit of support
and love.
SCOTT FUJITA: Yeah,
it's about kids.
It lets them say,
I am not alone.
And like Brendon said,
it will save lives.
There's no doubt in my mind.
Like the young lady who I met
down in the GLAAD awards, it
will save lives.
There's no doubt in my
mind about that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So you mentioned
Jason Collins.
I thought it was interesting.
In your brief to the US Supreme
Court, you have the
quote here, "no active athlete
in any of the major male
sports has come out, as
professional athletes,
themselves, feel the impact of
homophobia." And then shortly
after that, Jason Collins did,
in "Sports Illustrated." And I
was wondering how you guys
felt about that.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Yeah,
Robbie Rogers, as well.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: I, just,
think it's so amazing.
And also there's something that,
really, is crazy is that
Brittney Griner, also, came out,
right and as a backstory,
she was a first round draft
pick in the WNBA.
She went to Baylor University,
and just, kind of impromptly
said, oh you know, I'm a
lesbian, or whatever.
And backstory, you don't
hear about it.
That's where we're trying to
get with the male athletes.
We want it to be a backstory.
We don't want it to be first
page of "Sports Illustrated,"
everybody's looking at it.
It's the biggest talk, and
it's a whole big deal.
Obama, Oprah--
I mean that's great, we
want the support.
But at the same time, we just
want people to be who they are
and to live their lives
and to be happy.
So Jason's going to do so much
for people, and he's going to
continue to work.
And it'll be, really, great to
see him, actually, play in a
game next year.
I don't know if happens.
And hopefully, if he does play
in a game, it'll be for the
right reasons, because a
basketball team needs him, not
because a basketball team
is trying to have a gay
athlete on a team.
So I think it's amazing.
And it, just, shows how far
we've come in such a short
amount of time, and it really
makes me feel bad for people
like Martina Navratilova or
Billy Bean or Esera Tuaolo.
These are all athletes that came
out in the '80s and '90s.
And now today, this
is being embraced.
And they lost endorsements.
They couldn't play in
tournaments, and they tried to
cover up stories and scandals.
And you know, it used
to be a sin.
They were considered sodomites
and all these crazy things.
And now today, we get to have
someone that's touted as a
hero, in large part,
because of the
people that came before.
SCOTT FUJITA: Yeah, while
it's great to have this
conversation, I think it'll be
even greater when we get to
the point where this
conversation
doesn't need to be had.
I mean you know, how great
of a deal would that be.
CHRIS KLUWE: Yeah, and really,
it comes down we're athletes.
We're playing a sport.
It shouldn't matter what your
sexuality is, because we're
out there to do our jobs to the
best of our abilities, and
sexuality plays no part in that,
except if you're forced
to cover it up, and you can't
play to the best your
abilities, because you're
worried about being revealed.
So that's why what Jason
is doing is so great.
He's, like, look, I'm not going
to have to deal with
this anymore.
Now I'm just going to focus
solely on playing basketball.
And that's awesome, because
that's what everyone should be
able to do.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Did any of
you guys have negative
repercussions from your teams
for being outspoken in favor
of equality?
SCOTT FUJITA: Talk
to this one.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I though Chris
might want to answer this.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO:
Stop the presses.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KLUWE: Oh boy.
I'm happy to be with
Oakland right now.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
CHRIS KLUWE: Yeah, well
I mean, it is
one of those things.
It's unfortunate, in the NFL,
that coaches and management
view any sort of speaking out
or attention as distraction.
And I don't think that
that's the case.
I think that you can be a
professional athlete, you can
play at a very high level, and
you can also raise awareness
for very important issues that
affect a large amount of
people in this country.
You know, you hear about all
these guys who have either
their charities or they have
their events or they're doing
fundraising for the NFL or
awareness for the NFL.
Well those are exactly
the same things.
You're having guys do things
away from football.
What is it about talking
about same sex
marriage or LGBT rights?
What does that, all of the
sudden, make a difference that
you can't play football
anymore?
So I think that's an idea that
we need to move away from-- is
that athletes, as role models,
have to be, only, about
sports, because athletes are
so much more than that.
I mean look at the three
of us, up here.
We're not just football
players.
We have so many other
interests.
And it, really, does a
disservice to people if you
slap a label on them and say
that's all you can be, whether
it be you're just a football
player, or you're just gay.
It goes for anything
in society.
SCOTT FUJITA: Yeah, we're people
first, football players
a very distant second.
And he said it perfectly.
You know, I don't want to say
that speaking out now is
frowned upon so much like
it was, even three
or four years ago.
I mean, the conversation,
again, is evolving.
You've got young people coming
up, like Chris just mentioned,
too, who are just more open,
more tolerant, more accepting.
And you know, the coaches have
got to accept that, because
you know, by and large, we
dictate the coaches' jobs,
too, so they've got
to get on board.
Our successes and failures
dictate their livelihood, so.
CHRIS KLUWE: And that's the
thing that drives me crazy is
the fact that if you think a
player being gay is going to
be a distraction--
well yeah, there will be
some media attention
for a week or two.
But think how much better that
player would play if he didn't
have to focus on hiding his
entire life from everyone
around him.
You think that's not
a distraction?
Are you kidding me?
That's the biggest distraction
you could possibly have.
SCOTT FUJITA: We need to get
past the point where something
like that would be viewed as
a negative distraction.
I mean, if you can't deal with
distractions in this business,
you don't belong in
this business.
I mean, you've got guys-- all
kinds of crazy issues, you
know, in-house fighting and a
potential coaching change in
the middle of the season--
those are distractions.
Someone being himself is not
a negative distraction.
CHRIS KLUWE: Not at all.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Scott,
why don't I start
with you on this one.
Do you think that the
professional sports leagues
have gotten better about
disciplining players when they
do make anti-gay slurs?
SCOTT FUJITA: Um yeah,
it's complicated.
In the NFL, I don't know
if we have disciplined
anybody yet for that.
And I'm sort of torn and on
the fence about that.
I mean, when a player speaks
his mind, do I think they
should be fined a whole bunch
of money for that?
I mean, they are exercising
their right to free speech.
I don't like it.
I have no problem pulling guys
aside to talk about it.
But if nothing else, the good
that comes from that is that
it starts another
conversation.
And the media jumps on guys,
right now, immediately right
after they say something.
And I never like
to be that guy.
I prefer a more diplomatic,
behind the scenes, approach.
I pull teammates aside,
talked about it.
I let them know why using the
word like faggot in the locker
room might be offensive
to so many people.
You never know if the guy
in the locker next to
you might be gay.
And he might equate that
as you saying, I
hate gay people, which--
I know you as a teammate,
I know you as a person--
you are not that way.
You do not hate gay people.
But again, it's just flipping
the conversation.
And that could happen so fast.
And a lot of people come from
a climate or a family
atmosphere or all their boys
back home, who, that's such a
common part of their
vernacular.
And they never thought
about it that way.
You know what?
That's right.
Maybe they do think that I hate
the people when I say
that, and I don't.
Maybe I should stop
saying that.
So it's, just, flipping
the conversation.
CHRIS KLUWE: Yeah, and I think
it's also about, not so much
punishment, it's about
awareness.
It's about making guys aware of,
I've said something that
can affect a whole group of
people, and I should realize
why what I said is wrong.
And you know, like, when Chris
Culliver made his statements
before the Super Bowl.
That's something that you don't
want to jump down his
throat and immediately
just discard him.
You want to help him realize why
what he said makes so many
people's lives so much worse.
And I think that's, really, the
key, like what Scott said,
is educating these guys and
just making them aware of
other people's lives.
And you see that a lot in our
Congress, in Republican
policymakers that, all of the
sudden, they have a family
member that comes out as gay,
and their voting switches
dramatically.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: He
was 25 years old.
He was born that way, but--
CHRIS KLUWE: Yeah right, so as
you see stuff like that.
A lot of times it takes that
personal connection, and a lot
of that is education.
It's realizing the fact that
there are other people out in
the world and learning
about that.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: I think
it is an education.
You bring a concept to somebody
that people are born
gay, and they, just--
oh my god, show me the proof,
show me the evidence, no way,
the Bible says--
I'm, like, damn.
It's like, I don't see Muslims
and Jews trying to ban bacon
double cheeseburgers, but you
zealots are trying to ban
freakin' gay marriage,
you know.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: So
it is an education.
And as much as I'm against
religion, I also believe it's
your right to have religion.
I'm always going to fight for
Just like you're trying to ban
gay marriage, I'm not going to
try to ban religion.
That's you're right.
That's your freedom.
It's what this country
was built on.
So the beautiful thing about
it is that when guys make
stupid-ass comments, and they
say these homophobic slurs,
they become our freakin'
best allies.
The story goes worldwide, just
like Emmett Burns tried to
blow me up, my boy Chris Kluwe
put his ass on the spot.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: And all
of the sudden, I'm getting
letters from Japan, Brazil, all
these different places,
and I'm sure Chris did, too.
And it just brought so much
attention to the cause.
And in large part, that's why
we're here, because some
freakin' jerk that people put
into a position of power to
help people was trying to take
people's rights away.
So they become our biggest
allies, even though Emmett
Burns-- we don't have time to
teach old dogs new tricks,
maybe we'll just wait
for him to die.
But guys like, for example,
Kobe Bryant-- it was so
amazing, a couple of years ago,
he dropped the "f" bomb
on national TV, was talking
to a ref, right?
And he was fined, and then
he did some stuff
with the LGBT community.
And then a couple months ago,
someone on his Twitter feed
dropped the "f" bomb on his
feed, and he tweets the guy,
hey man, you can't say that.
It's wrong, and this
is why it's wrong.
And then that tweet goes
worldwide-- oh, Kobe's come
full circle.
I thought it was so beautiful.
And even Chris Culliver, he
went and worked with the
Trevor Project, and it was
really crazy, because all that
stuff happened during the Super
Bowl, And I didn't know
who he was.
I looked him up on Twitter,
and he was following me.
So nobody knows this, I
dropped him a message.
And he never heard back
from me, but I
know he got the message.
And I said--
it's kind of sick that I love
when the guy makes the
mistake, because the first thing
I do is I go to reach
out to them--
I'm an Athlete Ally.
You know, and I'm, also,
a football player.
And I love my athletes, and I
mean, we're all so different.
Athletes are different.
There's so many special
and amazing guys.
Even Adrian Peterson is a
special and amazing guy.
And how do we make
him an ally?
So the first thing
I do is I go and
I'll send him a message.
I sent Culliver a message.
I'm like, my man, you have a
chance to make this right, and
I have your back.
So then he went, and he did
the Trevor Project.
And I didn't know what the
Trevor Project was, so I'm
like, damn, he's going and
doing the Trevor Project.
I've got to go do the
damn Trevor Project.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: I can't
let a guy that was a past
homophobe-- frickin', I'm an
ally, I've got work to do.
So I called Abbe Land from
the Trevor Project, and
now she's my boy.
You know, we be texting it up.
She's also the Mayor
of West Hollywood.
And so we chop it up.
We're cool, and that's all
because of Chris Culliver.
And we're all here because
of Mr. Burns.
So thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT FUJITA: Thank you
for your bigotry.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: You're
changing the world
more than we are.
It's freakin' amazing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I wanted to ask
you guys about a few other
topics, and then I'll
open it up to
questions from the audience.
Scott, I know you're working
on a bunch of other causes.
So I was hoping you could talk
to us about some of those and
maybe let people, here, know
how Google might be able to
help with those.
SCOTT FUJITA: Yeah, I'm
kind of a busybody.
I just retired, like
Stacy said earlier,
a few months ago.
And my plan was to, sort of,
just decompress and catch my
breath and enjoy the kids.
But I don't sit still
very well, at all.
I'm an up-late-at-night kind of
guy, always ideas circling
in my head, a million
things I like to do.
But yeah, I have a lot of
causes that I'm very
passionate about, one of
which you mentioned,
breast cancer awareness.
My mother's a two-time breast
cancer survivor, so that's
always been close
to home for me.
Adoption is another one.
Gulf Coast restoration, given
that I got to New Orleans not
long after Katrina.
I was, actually, the first
free agent to go to New
Orleans after Katrina.
People thought I was nuts.
Oakland was the other
option, though.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT FUJITA: That would have
been more nuts, at the time.
But one of the groups I work
with right now is a group
called Team Gleason.
My former teammate in
New Orleans, who
these guys know well--
he's just, kind of, really
an iconic figure in New
Orleans, right now.
Big time special teams player
down for the Saints for about
seven or eight years, blocked
what I call the punt heard
around the world.
And the Superdome is reopening,
Monday night
Football, the first
game back in--
BRENDON AYANBADEJO:
--a war zone.
SCOTT FUJITA: --after Katrina
against the Falcons.
Steve was diagnosed with ALS,
Lou Gehrig's diseased in
January of 2011.
And Steve and I are--
I'm one of his closest
friends.
And he reached out to me not
long after he got the
diagnosis, right here
in San Francisco.
And it was just devastating.
He had been having some
symptoms for a while.
We knew that was a possibility,
but here is, 33
years old, we never imagined,
in your wildest dreams,
someone his age would be
afflicted with a horrific
disease like that.
And I lost my uncle to ALS about
17 years ago, so I knew
firsthand how difficult this
would be for he and his wife.
So Steve started a group
called Team Gleason.
And our foundation--
I'm on the Board
of Directors--
we do these crazy, wacky
adventures all the time,
because that's the kind
of guy Steve is.
Kind of the premise and the
mission of the foundation is
to push the envelope
on technologies.
And that's why I'm so happy to
be here on Google's campus
today, because people like
Steve, they need help.
The way he communicates now is
with his eyes through software
on his wheelchair.
He has a tablet device in front
of him with a bar over
the top that has these
infrared cameras,
which scan his eyes.
His eyes lock onto a keyboard
on his screen.
If they lock onto a letter for
2/10 of a second, that
registers a letter.
And he could click Speak at the
end typing a word with his
eyes, and then it
comes through a
program called CereProc.
It's a synthetic voice that
he generated while
he could still speak.
So it's kind of a new age
version of my good friend
Steve Gleason's voice.
It still sounds like him, but
the problem is that he can
only type about 10 or
15 words a minute.
And people don't have the
patience for that.
And that's where patients like
Steve are struggling, because
they're so marginalized.
No one can hear what
they have to say.
No one has the patience to sit
around and wait for him to
complete a sentence.
So you come to a place like
Google, and I think, here are
some of the brightest tech
minds in the world.
There's got to be a way we can
improve technology like that.
And I recognize that, again,
it's a marginalized group.
There's only 30,000 people
really afflicted by this.
But there's got to be ways to
make something like that
appeal to the mass market.
This is a guy who only
has use of his eyes.
He can control everything
with his eyes if the
technology is there.
And there's got to be a way to
make that appeal to the mass
market and get it on the radar
of a place like Google.
Why not?
So if there's anybody in here
who's listening or works with
Google Glass or anything
like that--
I know there's got
to be a way.
I'd love to talk, afterwards,
with you guys, because there's
got to be a way to help people
like my friend, Steve, who is,
just, amazing.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: And just
to interject, we have a
gentleman by the name of O.J.
Brigance, also in the Ravens
organization, that's suffering
from ALS, as well.
And Stephen Hawking is suffering
from ALS, and you
see how Stephen operates, and
you see him on TV and stuff.
So you can get a visual
of what our
brothers are going through.
The rates of ALS are higher in
football players and soccer
players, and so they are kind
of making a correlation
between repeated blows
to the head.
You know, the soccer players are
heading the soccer balls
and whatnot.
It's something that actually
I worry about.
For some reason, I just
think, like man, this
could happen to me.
So it'd definitely be amazing
if some of you geniuses in
here could figure
out something.
I mean, I'm kind of bummed
out that I have a wire on
my lav right now.
Like, I was thinking it would
be a wire-free lav.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Anybody?
No.
CHRIS KLUWE: A holographic
prompt?
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: Same old
lav from high school, here?
But it's a serious cause, and it
would be so amazing if you
guys could help in this
arena in this space.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think
we have a video--
do think we have time
for it, Jimmy?
SCOTT FUJITA: I can queue
it up you're--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great.
SCOTT FUJITA: --getting ready.
So Steve, he came up to the
Cleveland this past season
when I was in season, and he had
what's called a diaphragm
pacemaker implanted that helps
his diaphragm function.
That's one of the things-- is
upper respiratory failure with
this disease.
He's in recovery after
the procedure.
He can't talk anymore.
He could just kind of
mumble a little bit.
He's in recovery, and
he pulls me aside.
He nods me over, and he
whispers in my ear.
He sort of mumbles and he says,
hey what are you doing
this April.
I said, I've got nothing
planned.
He said I want to go
to Machu Picchu.
And I said, as in Peru.
And he says, yeah, I want to
take me to Machu Picchu.
So I said, I have no idea how
in the hell we're going to
pull that off, but that's just
the kind of guy he is.
We do these crazy expeditions,
and we always bring another
ALS patient with us.
So we did it.
We carried two grown men with
ALS to Machu Picchu.
So GoPro sponsored us, and I had
a GoPro camera strapped to
my chest the whole time.
And this is, kind of, a teaser
reel that Team Gleason put
together in a full length
feature that will air
on ESPN this Fall.
So it's about creating
awareness, getting this on
people's radar, and again,
trying to push the envelope on
the technologies to make these
people's lives easier.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you
for sharing that.
SCOTT FUJITA: Yeah, thank you.
It was an epic trip.
And the way Steve communicated
with me on most of that trip
was with his eyelids.
You know, I leaned him
back, you OK, buddy,
you need some water.
It was with his eyelids-- yes,
no, and that's about it.
So we've got to fix that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Chris,
question for you.
CHRIS KLUWE: Mhm.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can you tell
us about your book that's
coming out?
Is it this month?
CHRIS KLUWE: Yeah, this
month, June 25th.
And it kind of builds off this
idea that the struggle for gay
rights is also a smaller
part of the
struggle for human rights.
And that's something that
societies as a whole have not
found a way to fix throughout
our entire history.
I mean, if you look at every
single civilization throughout
the span of human history,
they have all failed.
And it's all been due to
a lack of empathy.
It's been due to a lack of being
able to put yourself in
someone else's shoes and
realizing that if this course
of action harms someone else,
then it's going to be
detrimental in the long run,
whether you create conflicts
from within, from oppressing
your own people, or if you
create conflicts from without,
by trying to take something
from someone else.
And so that's one of the main
ideas in this book is that, as
a civilization, if we want to
stand the test of time, if we
want to last in geological
terms, we have to figure out
how to preach and teach empathy
to all the members of
our society.
And even if we can't get
everyone, we can
treat it like a vaccine.
If we get 90% of the people in
our society to have empathy,
it acts as herd immunity.
And then the people who don't
have empathy, you can limit
the damage that they do.
And so it's this broader look
of what does it mean to be
successful civilization,
and are we going to
be able to do that.
And then there's also a lot of
random stuff, like funny
writings, short stories, my
letter to Emmett Burns.
There are various
other things.
And it's really, I like to
describe it as a look inside
my mind, so buyer beware.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KLUWE: One of the
underlying foundations is this
idea that we have to treat
people the right way, and it's
not a hard concept.
It's A very easy philosophical
concept.
It's treat others the way you
would like to be treated.
I mean, we all learned
it in kindergarten.
It's really simple, so yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Questions
from the audience?
Susie?
Are there efforts to teach the
coaches, so when they're
coaching young kids, they can
start learning about equality?
CHRIS KLUWE: It's funny you
mention that, because I have
actually been contacted by
guy called Coach Randy.
And he's in the process of
writing a book on how to be a
better coach.
I guess he's spoken in New
York, and he's one of the
assistant athletic people, I
think, for the softball team
at Rutgers.
So he is well familiar with
the whole bullying thing.
And his goal is to write a book
that people can use as a
resource for coaches, in that
there is a right way to coach,
and you don't have denigrate the
kids under your power in
order to coach well.
Because that, ultimately,
doesn't teach anyone anything
useful in life.
It teaches you to scream at
people, that's about it.
So he's working on that.
He's been asking my advice on
kind of, OK, how do I go about
approaching this
and what to do.
And hopefully, he'll be able
to kind of parlay that into
something that people pay
attention to and listen to,
because coaches are a very
important role model,
especially for young kids.
You know, a lot of your
behavior you pick
up from your coach.
I think he's doing a great
thing, and I fully plan on
supporting him in getting that
message out, that bullying is
not acceptable, whether
it's player to
player or coach to player.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: For me, I
like to talk to the parents
and educate the parents.
Before you have your child on
a team, you should talk to
that coach.
You should feel out that coach
and let him know that you're
not going to put up with any
type of discrimination on any
sports teams that your
children play on.
And that also opens up the
conversation to their children
and having this conversation
with their children about LGBT
rights and LGBT inclusion.
So when you have those
tough conversations--
and maybe I'm preaching
to the wrong crowd.
Usually, I'm talking to straight
people or sometimes
even LGBT people, but it really
doesn't have to address
them in this issue on how to
talk about inclusion, because
they already do.
So you have to bring up tough
issues like molestation or
bullying or LGBT awareness
and letting
your kids be sensitive.
That's exactly why my kids
are here, today.
I want them to be around
the LGBT community.
I brought them to a black tie
event last night, and they
were freakin' atrocious--
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDON AYANBADEJO:
--and screaming.
But I try to tell them--
I want my kids to be around the
smartest, the brightest,
the best people in the world,
and we all know that that
comes from the LGBT community.
That comes from society.
So it opens the door.
I talk to the parents.
I tell them, you know, exactly
what you should expect from
your coaches and what you will
not put up and tolerate with.
And then have the conversation
with your children, as well,
about some of these other
tough issues.
SCOTT FUJITA: Well said, guys.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT FUJITA: It's
about teaching
empathy, like Chris says.
There's so many coaches at the
youth level, high school
level, all over the country.
You can't get your hands
on all of them.
You do your best by speaking
out publicly.
When Chris writes a letter,
like he did,
everybody sees that.
These coaches see that.
It puts it on their radar.
Again, you can't get your
hands on everybody,
as hard as we try.
But it's all about flipping
the conversation.
I know I keep saying that,
but it's about empathy.
Teach empathy.
I mean, you can still
teach toughness
in the game of football.
This is a tough game, but you
can, also, teach empathy.
There's nothing wrong
with that.
CHRIS KLUWE: For me, it's
the fact that it is a
generational issue.
And the fact is older people,
right now, have not grown up
in an environment where they've
been around gay
people, openly gay people, so
to them that's going to be
their natural reaction
is that--
even if they're supportive,
they're going to be, like,
look, do what you want to do,
but just leave me out of it.
I don't want to know about it.
The thing is, as our kids grow
up, as the younger generations
grow up, they have gay friends,
they have gay
siblings, they have gay
teammates, and they
know about it now.
You have that education, where
that's how society will shift.
And unfortunately,
like I said, it
is a long term change.
It's not something you can just
flip a switch and all of
the sudden everyone's like--
I understand now, I'm being a
dick to someone, I probably
shouldn't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KLUWE: It's going
to take a while.
And the key is that if you think
someone is receptive
enough, you can tell them, look,
you may not want to know
about it, but this is part
of someone's life.
This is part of my life, and I
would like you to know about
it, so then you can understand
where I'm coming from.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: I. Always,
say that the LGBT community
is, obviously, a disenfranchised
group, so how
are they going to let people
know that we need rights, we
need to be treated equal.
You're going to see--
that's why it's a big deal that
Jason Collins comes out.
It shouldn't be, but it's
something that's never
happened before, and how else
are they going to change
things, unless they get allies,
unless they get the
majority of the population to
believe in their cause, which
is kind of crazy to me that we
even vote for this, that it's
even up to popular opinion.
So I just try to explain to
them, what would you do?
I mean, what did Martin
Luther King do?
What did Rosa Parks do?
They screamed for
attention, and
eventually, things changed.
And the LGBT community
is no different.
SCOTT FUJITA: Yeah, change
can be slow.
At the time of Loving versus
Virginia, I think only 13% of
the country was on board with
interracial marriage.
It wasn't until, I think, 1990
that at least a simple
majority of this country
was on board
with interracial marriage.
That's 1990, so change
is slow.
And it can't get at the
whims of the voter.
The fact that we're voting on
something like marriage
equality makes no sense to me.
I mean, you can't follow
the whims of the
voter, the mob mentality.
It's got be the government.
Brendon said that earlier.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO:
And I tell guys--
I'm like, there's countries
where they practice genital
mutilation.
There are societies where they
ate people and sacrifice them
to the gods, and that's because
that was the popular
thing to do.
That's what they thought was
the right thing to do.
So it's no different today.
I mean, we think we're
civilized, and we claim to be
the greatest country in
civilization, ever, but yet
our neighbors in Mexico and our
neighbors in Canada, they
have marriage equality.
So I just try to educate guys
and let them know this is why
it's like this.
We have to make a change.
There's people that are
yearning, begging to be
treated equally, and we're
not doing that.
And that's what America was
founded on, and quite frankly,
the Constitution is not living
up to it's end of the bargain.
So I let them know.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So the question
is, essentially, does
there need to be education for
gay people about whether
athletes who use terms that
are viewed as hostile are
really hostile toward
the gay community.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: I think we
saw, just last week, with Roy
Hibbert-- are you guys familiar
with the young man
from the Pacers?
He was talking, and he's like,
yes, my coach at Georgetown, I
love him, he's a great coach.
My teammates, yada yada
yada, I love them.
So I was, like wow, I'm really
impressed with this young man,
he's not worried about saying
he loves other men, which
other guys have a
problem about.
But then as soon as I felt that,
he made a compliment or
something to one of the other
players, and then he said, "no
homo." I was, like, aw, he
doesn't get it, you know.
But do I believe that he's
homophobic, that he means any
ill will towards the
LGBT community?
No, I don't, but that's
what we talk about.
There's education that
needs to take place.
A conversation needs to take
place, and that's what we're
here to do, and that's
what we're doing.
But we have a long
ways to go, so we
just continue to educate.
And there are a lot of athletes
that don't have ill
will towards the LGBT community,
and there are some
that clearly do.
And I think at the end of the
day, I want to get to the
point where we look on
homophobia like we look on
racism, like, that person
obviously has a problem, and
how do we address
that problem.
SCOTT FUJITA: It's funny you
mentioned "no homo." I think,
about a year ago, I sent out a
tweet that said, whoever the
fifth grader was that coined the
phrase, "no homo," how did
he gain all that traction?
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT FUJITA: People
responded.
They'd say, really, a fifth
grader coined that?
I said, no, I was making
a joke about it.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KLUWE: Sarcasm
at its best.
SCOTT FUJITA: The brightest
minds in the world live on
Twitter
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KLUWE: Yeah, I've seen
that, actually, because
growing up, I was the
nerdy, bookish kid.
Like, my glasses were, like,
that big and probably, about
that thick.
And I was, always, walking
around reading a book.
So I was more the nerd who
played athletics than the
athlete who read books.
And so for me, personally,
there's a little bit of a
label that is justly earned by
athletes in that a lot of
guys, their entire identity
is wrapped up in--
I am a football player, or I am
a soccer player, or I am a
baseball player.
And anyone else who's not that,
I look down, because
that's just the way
that I was raised.
And so that's something that,
as athletes, we need to show
that we are beyond that, because
that's the way we
become closer to these other
communities, like the LGBT
community, that we show it's no
longer you're finding the
gay kid and beating him
up during recess,
because that's happened.
That's been the underlying
story of our society.
There's a reason there's that
jock stereotype, so we need to
work on changing that and
showing that just as gay
people aren't defined by that
label, being gay isn't all
that you are, being an athlete
isn't all that you are.
You are much more than that.
You are a complex human being.
You are everything that
goes into you.
And so that's what we're trying
to show is that we
aren't just football players.
We are more than that.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: We have to
get our football players to
believe that, as well.
CHRIS KLUWE: Yeah.
BRENDON AYANBADEJO: That's why
you see a lot of the guys that
end up, probably, going bankrupt
and losing their
money, it's because after
football's over-- who are
they, who am I, where do I go.
And that's, probably, a lot of
the same guys that are saying
"no homo" and a lot
of these things.
CHRIS KLUWE: Yeah, they just
don't know how to identify
themselves once that athlete
label is gone.
That's all they are, and they
have to move past that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well I wish we
could stay here and talk all
day, but I'm being told
we need to wrap up.
So I wanted to be sure to thank
you guys on behalf of
everyone at Google for coming
here and for your eloquent
advocacy on behalf of
marriage equality.
So thanks a lot.
This has been great.
[APPLAUSE]